Here’s how you make a baby through sex
from the perspective of a chromosome
When mom makes an egg,
her chromosomes double
Divide
And then divide again
Some end up in the egg
The rest are discarded into much smaller polar bodies
Now we have an egg, it meets a sperm,
and it’s baby business time
Let’s go back to the part
where the mom’s chromosomes separate
It’s been a tenet that this process is random
This chromosome sometimes goes into the egg
Sometimes into the polar body
Its homolog sometimes goes into the egg
Recent studies now suggest this sorting
is not so random after all
Instead there might be a selfish gene at work
preferentially dragging
its home chromosome into the egg
and causing its match to get thrown away more often
The element is actually the centromere
-- a stretch of DNA in the chromosome
important for mechanically separating them
during cell division
It is the anchor point for the spindle--
the spot on the chromosome that gets pulled on
by the machinery of the cell
It turns out there are strong centromeres and weak ones
And the strong ones get passed down preferentially
How is this a selfish gene?
Well, centromeres are repetitive stretches of DNA
In fact ,centromeric repeats are the most abundant
non-coding elements in the human genome
Centromeres in preferentially inherited chromosomes in mice
have been shown to much bigger
--and they recruit more proteins
which are used to hook onto the spindle
These are the strong centromeres --
and they tend to end up pointing towards
the egg-end of the cell when it's dividing
But strong centromeres
does not mean stronger attachment --
Instead, they are more likely to let go
of their spindle attachment,
if it is pulling them towards the polar-body side
-- away from the egg-to-be-side.
Because this mechanism depends on
tension between the 2 chromosomes,
when the strong one lets go,
the weak one, has to let go too
It’s like restarting a game if you’re
not winning
So, eventually, with enough stops and starts,
the strong centromere is reoriented,
heading for the egg side and possible inheritance
and the weak side is heading for the dumpster
How does the centromere know which way it's going?
The thought is the stronger centromere
listens in on a signal broadcast by the membrane,
that is intended to help the cell divide asymmetrically
the selfish centromere takes advantage of this signal
to recognize which way it is getting dragged
Why aren't we seeing bigger and bigger centromeres
if they are preferentially placed into the egg?
It turns out that what’s good for these genes
might not be great for the egg or the body
-- making these strong centromeres truly selfish
genes
When researchers have scanned
the genome for rapidly evolving proteins
-- centromere-binders --
those that attach to the centromere for some reason
-- are amongst the fastest
possibly because the rest of the genome is fighting back
So the question is--
How selfish are your centromeres?